we've sounded the alarm in this show
about the decrepit state of New York
City's Penn Station it's the busiest
train station in this country it should
be great because this country is great
but it's not it's filthy filled with
waste and we said as much on this show
have you been at Penn Station recently
it's a shelter it's disgusting it's a
waste you give these speeches I just
read one where you're like you know
Trump is bad
by the way ignore the guy living you
know under the ATM machine we're
relieving himself dead serious question
have you been the men's room and Penn
Station
well there are surprise and happiness
really Amtrak which operates Penn
Station called us and said they had
revamped the place and cleaned up its
men's rooms we want to see if that was
true so he sent the intrepid Brett
Larson to investigate here's what he
found it's not every day you get an
invite for an exclusive one-on-one tour
of the men's bathrooms in New York's
notorious Penn Station so eager to show
us their newly renovated bathrooms they
threw up the police barricades and
cleared out the customers and had us
meet them at 3:00 a.m. well how can we
pass that up in the middle of the night
we've got a very close up and personal
demo of the new all-in-one sinks
then you move to the next up water
but remember Penn Station is notorious
for its problem with homelessness the
down-and-out and drug abusers come here
each night to hang out the place
literally becomes a homeless encampment
in the winter and guess where they go to
bathe each night that's when we noticed
the new Sync designs these aren't very
deep so I'm guessing it's you're not
gonna splash water you probably couldn't
even splash water in your face under
there no you could not get over there no
chance of getting an arm or leg under
that thing Amtrak was eager to tell us
how they've evolved how Penn Station is
becoming more of a destination transit
hub and less of a third-world slump we
don't want people to necessarily feel
that way or have that opinion we want to
invoke a great experience that you're
not only coming from the Train but
you're getting off the train as well
that the journey doesn't end just off
the train exit the fancy new restrooms
and it's the same old intimidating Penn
Station of yesteryear exit on 7th Avenue
and you're greeted with people sleeping
on the floor exit on 8th Avenue same
deal and there's this opposite Madison
Square Garden dozens of homeless people
camping out for the night others
seemingly up to no good at all not
everyone dislikes Penn Station however
it's a nice clean station good for
departures good for you know your
destinations we had one last question
for the Amtrak guy he filters to get rid
of the pee smell and those in the actual
terminals or is that part of the
nostalgia yeah okay it smells like urine
when you're walking around sometimes no
I mean obviously we're looking at
everything to make a better customer
experience ah better customer experience
that's what you're gonna get in that
restroom as well as the women's restroom
newly renovated at Penn Station as for
the rest of Penn Station that transit
hub here in the middle of Manhattan one
of the most expensive cities in the
country if not and also one of the most
expensive cities in the world it is
still the same old same old dump as we
saw there at 3:00 in the morning but
you know this it doesn't matter if it's
3:00 in the morning or 3:00 in the
afternoon or rush hour or a weekend day
Penn Station is always disgusting and
frankly it's embarrassing when you take
Amtrak from DC you get on at the
beautiful Union Station which is this
right gorgeous train station that's been
restored Grand Central Station if you go
in the main hall is beautiful you get
off in Penn Station and it literally it
feels like you've arrived in some
terrible hellscape and the you know
maybe maybe the monkeys did win and or
the Apes rather from Planet of the Apes
that's what like you're just walking out
to like what is this we should have more
self-respect than that we really should
it's it's it's embarrassing it's totally
embarrassing and congrats to Amtrak for
new bathrooms but you know there's a lot
more to Penn Station than two restrooms
well you're a brave man breath thank you